Hello, hello, hello everyone.
Hello.
Hi.
How we doing?
Hello.
Condense.
That's our greeting.
Condensation.
One and all.
Did you guys notice anything new and cool about...
About our stream?
Oh, anything shiny?
Shiny, shiny, shiny.
Besides our beautiful foreheads.
Anything else?
And Phoebe's beautiful eyes.
And Minto's beautiful eyes.
What about my beautiful eyes?
And your beautiful...
Oh, yeah, you're beautiful.
Oh, wow.
Whoa, whoa.
So shiny.
So shiny and beautiful.
Wow.
You're so beautiful.
Can I just...
Give it a nice...
It's my smooch.
Oh, I give it a smooch.
It's like, you know, they're like cultures where you rub the
elephant statue, you get good luck.
You smooch the mental head.
The bald head.
And you get good luck.
I take off my hair and I'm covered in like little lipstick
stains.
Yes, but she has to allow you.
You have to...
Just like a vampire, you must ask permission first.
through.
Or else you will be cursed, the blinding stew.
Blinding stew?
The blinding stew.
Yeah.
The three-day blinding stew.
Yeah, if you do not ask permission, you will be cursed with
the three-day blinding stew.
Yes.
Is it nice?
I don't know if it takes three days to make or if it means
you're blind for three days.
Which one?
I don't know.
I always assumed it was blind for three days, but...
How good is the stew?
Yeah.
Is it good enough to be?
Is it worth being blind to eat the blind?
For three days.
Yeah.
Maybe you eat it for three days too.
Maybe that's another thing.
You also eat the three day blinding stew for three days.
And someone says you have to make it in three days, but
you're blind when you make it.
There's too many variables here.
I think we need more.
accurate information before we any blinding stew experts in
here wait i have a question for you guys because this was
relevant till two days ago i was cooking and i was cutting
an onion and it was the most pain one of the most painful
things i've ever experienced like there it's not just a
cartoon thing yeah no i don't know why that onion was
particularly pungent i was gonna say was this your first
time of a cutting well no it just never made me cry that bad
before i was i was then like my nose was sniffling and my
eyes were i couldn't keep my eyes open so i was like i
shouldn't be chopping onions with my eyes closed but it's
like a black onion i have a i have a a a life hack you oh i
i put them in the freezer and then what or you run them
under like a cold water and that will make it so that they
don't blind you another life If you wear contacts, it's much
better as well.
Is it?
Then you rub your eyes.
No, but the eyes is fine because it like keeps the, I don't
know, the wind of the onion out of your eyes.
I don't know how to explain it, but it definitely is better
when I'm wearing contacts.
Wait, that might be why I've never really cried while
chopping onions because I wear contacts a lot.
I didn't have them on that time.
Oh, that's what it is.
That's what it is.
It's all the onion juices.
For onion chopping.
Wait, is it not worse to have a contact?
What about glasses that would stop the wind, right?
I had glasses on.
I was crying through my glasses, so I guess.
It's like the contact covers the whole of the surface of
your eye, right?
Whilst the glasses, like that onion air can get in there
underneath, you know?
That onion air.
If it wants to get in your eye, it's going to get in there.
You need full goggles, yeah.
that there's lab like wearing a lab coat lab goggles just to
cut an onion a hazmat suit well now i know the pro tips and
tricks put it in the freezer and wear your proper ppe for
for onion chopping yeah everybody learned too nobody knew
that before this is like reminding me of this really random
thing in school did you guys have to do like dissections in
science class so like They made us dissect an onion, like,
under the microscope.
And me and my friends started a campaign, Justice for
Onions.
Well, I was reminded me of this, but...
Yeah.
We did something similar.
My sister and I would go to the grocery store, and we would
protest by the lobsters, and we would say, free the
lobsters.
Yeah!
My sister and I would make animal sanctuaries We're
creatures like roly-poly's and ants.
Aww, that's cute.
Wait, that is so cute.
We are all conservationists here.
And then setu.
I think you guys like more than me, but okay.
Dot green.
Every hue, every green and green and green.
And green.
Make the world so green.
We all have green on us.
It's perfect.
Oh, yeah, wait.
I've got my ribbon.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're right.
I got my stem.
I'm in my dress.
I'm green.
Yeah.
You are.
You are John Green.
John Green.
Wait, what Earth Day?
Wasn't Earth Day just the other day?
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, today is Earth Day.
Oh, today is Earth Day.
No way.
In the U.S.
It is Earth Day.
Happy Earth Day, Daisy!
Look after the Earth, guys!
Wait, what a perfect conversation!
That's crazy.
Totally unplanned.
That's crazy!
Wait!
Oh, okay, wait, my sister just sent me this.
I want to link it to you guys.
There's Earth Day Chow Sonic shirts.
Wait, these are so cute!
They're so cute!
I'll put in the...
I need them!
They're so cute!
Oh my gosh, can we...
Can we wear these and go out hiking in nature, guys?
That would be so fun!
These are so cute!
Please!
I think we should sing Happy Birthday to the Earth.
Yeah!
Yeah.
Okay.
okay happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you that's lovely Happy birthday Earth.
Happy birthday Earth.
And what perfect way, yeah, it's actually a perfect game
choice as well, spending time in nature.
Maybe not the endless, you know, drinking and smoking and
throwing trash on the road, but the driving through nature,
sure.
Yeah.
It's actually the perfect game, my thing.
Wow, this is completely on accident too.
We're so in sync with the Earth.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Wow.
When do you guys want to head over to to said game?
Give me give me a signal.
Oh my god, what's going on?
I just had a look at the game.
Hello.
Okay.
I'm switching.
I'm switching over.
Okay.
Lads, you ready?
Let's go.
Turn to the BGM.
Fan lines.
I need to fail the baby.
Oh yeah.
Cool-aid dude.
Hey lights ready.
Come on, you guys know, you guys know Den said to MVPs, or
if you don't, you should listen to it.
What are you doing?
I like how you just got feet in your view.
Yeah, as you guys can tell, it's my POV today, as can be
seen by the moose on my head.
Last time on RV there yet.
Vicky somehow became one with the moose.
You're not holding it, are you?
Can you keep the moose?
Like, can you hold?
Yeah, I mean, guys, I don't even know how to take it off.
Like, I'm not pressing anything right now.
So I guess we're stuck with it.
What happened there?
So, guys, I'm like, blue.
bleeding how dare you we're trying to get my hands on with
you guys this is I mean if this ain't aura farming I don't
know what is look at me right now wait where'd you guys go
okay okay so yeah we decided um it's so good do you guys
remember what we called the moose yeah how long has it been
since we played this game I think like it was our very first
collab right I think so Wait, no, November, December,
January, February, March, April.
It's been like six months at least.
It's been like half a year.
Almost, yeah.
It's not been six months.
I haven't.
It's been, it's been two years, actually.
It's been 84 years.
It's been nine years.
I think it's been like six or seven years, maybe.
The silence is, is just killing me, please.
Let's just go.
Let's just go already.
Please put me on my misery.
I thought I disconnected.
Oh my gosh.
Um, did anyone want to drive in particular or did we want to
go back?
I know last time I was in the middle of driving.
Can I do, can I suggest the opposite thing?
Can I suggest that I don't drive?
Is that okay?
Because when I tried last time, it did not go well.
I mean, I could attempt, but...
As long as you can tell your moose to stop looking me in the
eye because he's really freaking me out.
Yeah, can he just look the other way?
Get moosed.
I think, isn't it that like moose are like a leading cause
of death in Canada or something?
I don't know.
They're very dangerous.
They are.
They seem dangerous.
Well, don't forget to buckle up on your moose, please.
Until we find out how to remove this moose, the POV will be
this moose for the entirety of the stream.
Oh no, how do we remove the voice?
I keep throwing her didn't work.
Would, would, would, I can't, it's time to kill you.
Yeah, I'm just sorry.
No, no, come on.
Here we go.
Guys!
Are you okay?
Oh, you're live.
They could have got it all floating in the deep.
In the deep.
You hide my moose inside.
Oh, I think I gotta move this here.
I'll move it.
I don't want the moose in my head.
Why am I swimming?
Okay, right.
How does this look from your guys' POV?
Is it just like a moose approaching you on the water?
Yeah, it's menacingly.
Wow, it's a miracle.
Menacingly.
Look at this moose walking on water.
Oh, Carr, why are you moving so much?
It's fine, probably.
It's fine.
Could have had it all.
Okay, I'll just, I'll just meet you guys on the side.
How about that?
Nice driving, guys.
Good job.
Oh, you gotta get it off of this?
Yeah, or else it'll...
The moose approaches like a majestic swan.
Oh my god, it really does just look like a moose is like
walking in the water.
Um, okay, okay.
Oh no, someone lost their hat.
Uh-oh.
Who lost their hat?
Was it Vicky?
Oh, it's Vicky.
Actually, I'm not sure.
I actually, huh?
Whoa, who's stop is this?
I think we just take it.
I got EpiPen.
Yeah, let's just take it.
I don't know how to use it, though, actually.
I don't know how to stop smoking.
Those brave souls who drove before us.
Alright, here we go.
How do I stop smoking?
It's first about determination and willpower.
You gotta be the one to really wanna stop the smoking before
you can.
You gotta wanna help yourself before you can help yourself.
So I think I want to help myself.
How, how, how, what is the first, first step after wanting
to help myself?
I think, um, take that cigarette out of your mouth and stomp
it on the ground and say, no more.
No more.
More bozo?
Yeah.
Oh, it's, it's, it's got a grip.
Oh, he'll let it.
I'm trying to, you go, girl.
You can do it.
No more.
Yeah.
No more!
You deserve a beer for life, Phoebe Chan, Jamie.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, Mentor.
Hold on, I'm gonna try and jump in the car and break it.
Oh, hang on.
Why are we so short?
Guys, I worked out how to drop the moose.
Should I drop it?
Drop it.
You figured it out!
Wait, drop it in the...
In the...
Oh, put it in the van.
Okay, nice idea.
Who's got it?
We got it.
There you go.
We're gonna put it in the van.
Nice.
You could probably put it on top of the car.
Oh, yeah.
There's room on top.
Oh, there's room on top.
Oh.
Let me move this wheel.
Is this how it feels?
Well, surely we won't need it.
We won't need the wheel.
All right, bring the moose and put him down.
I'm having an accurate experience of what it feels like.
Oh, there we go.
Finally.
Oh, no.
We don't need the wheels.
How do you do it?
Honestly.
Can't drop here.
Why can't I drop here?
Will it let you attach to the shelf?
Which one's the shelf?
The thing you're standing on.
I guess not.
Oh, this thing?
Yeah.
Yeah, I guess not.
No.
I'll try to drop him in the van.
Yeah, yeah.
Why?
Oh, you might need to come in through the ceiling.
Oh, wait.
Let me, I can grab him maybe.
Oh, you can grab him?
Okay.
Hand them off to me.
Oh wait, I can pick you up.
I can pick you up.
Come here, come close, come close.
There we go.
Oh yes.
This looks really funny.
There we go, there you go.
Can't drop you.
I was imagining like a titanic scene, but then Phoebe's
holding the moose at the same time.
I think you might have to, he's yours now, Phoebe.
Okay, I'm just gonna abandon him.
No, I don't want him.
Wait, no, no, please.
Don't abandon him.
Look at him in the water.
don't leave him I'll take care of him I'll take care of him
Okay But then we might have to leave you No I can get inside
I can get inside You can get inside Well Okay Actually We
probably want to take her No I don't want Yeah take the
wheel Yeah we'll take the wheels back Jesus take the wheel
Okay I'm finally back in the van If I can do anything to
help Take my moose with me Cause I won't leave him on his
own Phoebe Chan she be yes get that out of your mouth oh my
god I didn't mean to it keeps coming back to me like a toxic
ex I can't even know I didn't even realize I think I'm
sleepwalking I'm sleepwalking do you tell that to the moose
right now you apologize to him wait for what for smoking you
because smoking causes forest fires.
He's the one who gave me the cigarette in the first place.
He said, hey, kid, hey, kid, you want some candy?
And then he's like, this candy's special.
You light it like a birthday candle.
And I was like, that's so cool.
And then it didn't taste like candy.
It's messed up.
That is messed up.
Maybe we should leave the moose here.
But he could, he sounds like a smooth talker.
I think he could get us out of some situations.
I reckon he could smooth talk the bad.
actually don't you think yeah let's get going then stop us
dying yeah oh nice beer go through the top yeah otherwise
you won't be able to go to go i think lovely all right i'm
ready i'm ready to go ready to go here we go okay you got
this got this i'm gonna come out the front people see what's
happening oh my god here i'll give you i'll give you this my
seat here you can take my seat thank you minto oh wow you're
good you're good yeah you're good third gear third gear
maybe fourth i tried to go to second gear but then it only
will let me use first right now Moose is like going through
the windshield.
How many gears are there?
They're doing great, Phoebe.
There are six.
We're sorry.
No, this one has five.
Oh, six, really?
Six gears, huh?
Four.
Six.
Sorry.
I got distracted.
This is why we should never meme while we drive.
Memes are dangerous on the road.
Don't meme and drive.
I think, actually, our camper needs repairs.
Maybe.
It does.
If you guys could repair it while I drive, that would be
fantastic.
In a constant need of repair.
How do we repair?
Yeah, how do we?
That's a great question.
Oh, but the back is now open.
Outside.
Pick up a hammer.
It feels like, oh, we lost our door, which is totally fine.
Actually, I don't mind the Jeep look.
Yeah.
It's refreshing.
From my POV, I cannot see what they're at.
Wait, stop it, Phoebe!
Stop!
I fell out!
Oh!
No!
Let me back, oh, this is a bad one, right?
Phoebe, I remember this place!
There's mines here!
This is a minefield!
Oh.
Right?
Isn't this?
Yeah, there's mines here!
I think...
Oh, no!
Oh.
Yeah, if we go further...
Wait, we went this far back, darn.
Yeah, we went pretty far, I think.
Oh.
From...
There's clothes here!
Your biggest fan.
Wait!
Where are we?
Oh, there's the... No, we didn't get that far back because
there's the...
There is the ramp that goes into the abyss and...
We just gotta cross that.
Okay.
There's a house with stuff in it.
Yeah.
Lots of beer.
Glasses and stuff.
Ooh.
Mm-hmm.
nice yeah oh let me see let me see guys want to see my fit
oh beautiful beautiful i love it thank you look like a diva
auntie yes you do oh my gosh another hat here is anybody
want this explorer hat safari hat six pack of beers we
definitely want that bear bear spray taking this bear spray
where'd the van go oh hi auntie hi hello auntie you are the
cool auntie i love i love this look where's motor oil do we
need that oh to repair the engine oh that might be good
interesting attached to show
oh yeah there is like a tool to repair things repair hammer
there you go Nice.
Oh, we got so much beer.
Let's go.
Okay, what needs repairing?
There we go.
Lots of things, apparently.
Oh, you okay.
Did I bonk you?
You might have.
That's totally fine.
I can kiss it better.
I'll kiss that bald head better.
I need a good...
Am I bald?
Wait, am I bald?
No.
No, but you're not.
you can would you become bald for me yeah i want that good
luck for you it's really hard to tell like when you're done
repairing i was just repairing into space for like five
minutes okay there we go right
good job team good job good job good job good job good job
team out of the house motor oil still i'm going to attempt
something with the moose oh yeah i want to see i'm
interested
from a reasonable distance oh wait that's so big brain from
a reasonable distance oh come on that touched that touched
it totally touched come on You got to veer to the left, I
guess, because of the incline.
Yeah, I'm going to try from up above me.
Yeah, maybe he'll slide onto it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
So close.
Okay, okay.
It's like an Olympic sport.
I'm so locked into this.
Oh, so close.
This guy.
And here we are, the ultimate moose-throwing champion.
That touched.
touch does anyone else want to attempt yeah sure i can try
yeah yeah go for it oh oh i'll film it for tick tock all
right here we go old to throw
whoa that touch i don't think it doesn't need much that's
scary to me i thought i thought she was I thought you were
going to run over me.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need to be careful.
Okay.
Okay, let's go further back.
Wait.
Oh, bad.
I don't know if it's going to work.
We definitely used something to set off the mines before,
though.
I don't remember what it was.
Maybe it was my body.
It might have been.
Holy
And the moose is still intact And the moose is still intact
Nice Yeah Then more up this way I think so You might want to
be careful I'm a little on fire Oh no Uh It's because you're
so hot Yeah you're fire You're fire I don't see any others,
so I think it's okay.
Oh!
Woo!
Are you okay?
You're good.
All right, what have we learned?
What have we learned, kids?
Never say...
Anything.
Rid of the bombs.
Thanks, Mitchell.
Thank you.
Good job.
I'm gonna look at the ground as I walk now.
It was in the grass!
Wait, that's so infest!
Yeah!
There's another one here.
Mine.
Oh, I see it.
Oh.
Alright, moose it.
I'm gonna stay back.
Oh yeah, okay.
Oh wait, yeah, you can do it!
Go!
Phoebe!
Oh, so close.
I...
Come on Yeah
I think we have to build this now Oh, there's another one,
there's another one Oh, oh, oh, oh, where?
It'll fall Too much
for me, thank you
Too close to the action Hey, that's how, that's a good
reporter right there Yeah Okay I think like this right oh we
definitely did this before do we want to lattice it i think
it's good to lattice it okay like a good old pie like a good
pie yeah where are you guys getting all these what are you
guys's favorite pie flavors a flea plea whoa oh actually
cherry cherry pie is like one of my favorites of Apple I
love a good apple pie apple pie and custard mmm I don't
think I've had a custard pie before no just like with
custard on the side no you dip it in the custard oh I don't
think I've had it with custard on the side either I don't
know if I have chocolate pie chocolate pie chocolate cream
pie where is the card where's the moose the moose is is
safe.
He's waiting by the loading zone.
Yeah.
We just gotta get the car in.
I'm surprised the bear hasn't shown up yet.
What was the lesson from earlier?
Never say anything.
Oh, gee, I'm so surprised the bear hasn't showed up yet.
Oh, well, it's surprising.
Well, it didn't, so we're fine.
I'll try driving.
I believe in you, Minto.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, uh, park.
Well, we have no more mines anymore, so I think we're okay.
Oops, that's good.
Oh.
I gotta go in the reverse, I guess.
How do I reverse?
Um...
It's also a gear.
Oh, oh, I see it.
Well, Fibi Chen, Shibi, a natural habitat at one with the
tree so beautiful happy earth day okay we're fine
everything's fine it's a good thing i got rid of this mine
right here just saying mm-hmm who's putting mines in the
forest that's not very earth day friendly of them it's the
bear or the moose the moose is going down right now oh we
need someone to press the button oh actually the moose is in
the way It's blocking me.
Okay, let me get it.
Let me get the moose.
Oh, God.
He's alive.
What was that lighting?
Can we climb the moose?
Oh, wow.
You can.
The lighting is going to a rave right now.
Oh, sorry.
I said a rave.
It looks like a deer.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh.
It looks like a deer in head.
All right.
Someone just got up.
Oh, sorry.
Oh.
I'm going if you if you're there you're good you're good go
ahead oh wait um all right we're I'm parking so now just
press the button and beam me up can you go forward a little
bit more okay you're now on it okay okay I'm on it
wow whoa here we go here we go chat how long do i think i
can stay here until i fall off oh let's test out oh wait for
you guys up here oh don't worry i'm on the car oh i'm just
kidding i'm stuck oh oh oh wait uh let me let me try
reversing all i see is the moose peering over the side of
the car can someone um push me You could go out and press...
Oh, the beer is.
I'm still on the ground.
Oh, okay, it's got to be me then.
Alright.
I'll go get a beer.
Let me drop the moose.
Okay.
Alright, so my calling.
Strong Vicky.
I need to be able to get in the van first to get a beer.
Okay, alright, here we go.
Oh.
Actually using a beer for the uses that it needs to be used
for.
How...
Push you how?
I think it's like yeah the problem is um so you're literally
like hanging over the edge I'll attempt but I can't make any
promises probably go up on top and like go to the over yeah
yeah I would go on the over on the lift whoa oh scary and
then I would push from behind okay yeah push from the lift
if you can yeah push my b-hank right there i don't know how
to get up there though i feel like i'm gonna fall down if i
attempt to go there oh i know i know i've got an idea i've
got an idea sorry i have a new idea right if i get in the
van okay get in the van go through the hatch and then go
through the hatch yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna see if
i can climb up this rock to get out of the hatch or can you
only get in through the hatch oh maybe you can only get in
oh no i mean i've managed to like glitch out of the back of
the van enough times that surely it's gonna happen.
No?
Okay.
Oh, but you've been.
Oh, what happens if I press the...
If I press the... No, if I press the button, then it's
definitely gonna screw everything up.
I need a lower...
Oh, yeah, I'll fall, probably.
Okay, I'm just gonna keep pushing from both sides.
Everyone says to press the button, but I don't trust it.
You know what?
I believe in chat and the Denchi.
They have our best interest at heart.
Yeah.
I know they do, but I...
I think I might be pushing the van further into turmoil.
Oh, I'm gonna...
Oh!
Yippee!
Wow, it actually worked!
Here you go.
Be here to celebrate.
Be here to celebrate, baby.
Bottoms up.
Chug, chug, chug.
I'm finding a way to get to you guys.
the vicky the vicky super strength came through guys um oh
where are you i found it i ran up oh nice okay oh okay there
you are running up that road running up that hill all right
is there another house oh this is that yeah there's another
house up here i remember oh
With some stuff.
Meat patty.
Thanks for becoming a member.
Thank you.
Patty!
So much meat.
So much burger.
And a ball.
Whoa.
Fine.
Definitely want to take some burgers back to the van.
And some...
Nuggets.
I got nuggets.
Wait.
Will this heal me?
Wow.
Where?
I'm chugging the...
Oh, just like a tiny, tiny bit.
Okay, there it is.
Oh.
Oh!
Well, that was terrifying!
Whoa!
I'm glad that worked out.
I'm so glad that worked out.
What happened?
Take the proper path back home, Mitch, is all I'm going to
say.
Holy cow!
Yeah, I'm not...
Wait, there's a bunch of loot under here, though.
There's a bunch of scrap.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
That was clearly on purpose, Vicky.
Because you knew there was loot there.
Yes, exactly.
How do you get inside?
It's from this way.
Guys, did we leave the moose up there?
We must bring the moose.
Bring the moose.
I'm going to make some burgers.
maybe yay actually where is our burger making machine oh
disposable grill
yeah oh there's a huh oh my oh it's too easy to do that okay
right this way oh lovely there's a cassette too what a
beautiful view for a barbecue yeah wait how do i make the
burger Oh, I'm releasing the burgers.
Okay, and then I'm gonna litter and then I'm gonna make the
burgers
Wait, drop How do I do this I don't know you need to make
sure it hits the barbecue.
Yeah Oh we away away away away away away away oh we oh we oh
we okay I ate a burger.
It didn't really do anything.
Looks good.
Oh, my bad.
That's a burger for somebody if they want to.
Can I have this burger?
Of course.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Oh, did it.
The moose wanted to get involved, I guess.
Yeah, we're making moose patties, then.
Yeah.
Oh, there's another burger for somebody.
A tasty burger.
Oh my god, wait!
Whoa!
I got an achievement!
Oh my god!
What are these?
Wait, you guys, one of these burgers is called Johnny.
Oh, God!
Really, Johnny?
We cooked him!
It's all my fault!
I cooked Johnny!
Ah!
No!
Well, I'm not gonna let him go to waste.
No.
This is what he would have wanted.
This is for your... in your honor, Johnny.
Johnny!
Soft burger.
Oh, sorry, sorry, I meant to...
Sorry, sorry, I meant to get a burger.
You can hold me.
It's fine.
I think the Johnny one will give me diarrhea, so I'm afraid.
I don't see the one named Johnny.
I don't see it.
Do the burgers go bad, or can we just make a store of them
in the van?
Yeah, what if we do that?
Okay, I'm just going to put a load of burgers on the seat.
I mean, that's kind of worrying that they don't...
Don't go bad, I'm not gonna think too much about that.
I mean, we've been carrying this moose for a long time.
Yeah, that was sweet.
Oh, me.
Six months of that vlog has been.
Oh, God.
It's the six month blinding moose.
Oh, no, Johnny sent a super chat and he's sad.
Johnny!
Johnny, we're sorry!
Oh, no!
Oh, Johnny!
Johnny!
I'm sorry!
Well, on the plus side, we've got a lot of food supply now.
So that's good.
Yeah, thanks for your sacrifice, Johnny.
Thank you.
I'm gonna...
Almost all my bones were broken, and now they're not.
Thanks to you, Johnny.
Hey, nice!
All right.
Phoebe, Phoebe, Phoebe.
You guys, I mean, I can attempt this drive again, but I
don't, you know.
I can try if you like.
Famous lost words.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I could get us to the top of the hill maybe, and then you
want to try.
Sure.
I will attempt.
I believe.
I don't understand gears.
Oh, my, oh, dear.
Okay, we're going back.
That's fine.
Vicky, Vicky, Vicky.
Oh, we might want to close the door.
The burgers are flying.
Do we...
Hold on.
Oh.
There.
Sorry.
Trying to get us up the hill.
Everything's fine down there, right?
Everything's fine?
Yeah, everything's fine.
He's absolutely under control.
I think I got us to the top of the hill.
it's all downhill from here okay okay you have to you have
to increase slowly but not too slowly the gears guys what
happens if i fail because i probably will we go back to
where we started oh my gosh the beginning of the stream wait
that's too much pressure okay can i i i need a whole crash
course in how to drive i think before i do this janai i i
literally don't know what i'm doing I can attempt e-drive.
Okay, how do I drive?
So, but before you go, before you go out of park, I want you
to look at the gears.
Hold down, I think it's Q.
Yeah.
You have to, like, use it.
You have to, like, change them with your...
Yeah.
So you'll go one.
Okay, one.
Oh, my God.
And then, wait a second.
Welcome back, Jenny.
Oh, Johnny's so happy.
We couldn't do it.
back.
Oh, we just we needed to we needed to die to bring Johnny
back, guys, right?
So true.
It was a necessary sacrifice.
Yeah, you know.
Needed to be done.
Right, Johnny, can you go on the top of the van?
And then another winch pole.
Winch pole.
I'm repairing Thank you While we're in like a safe spot I'm
gonna I'm gonna try that again Maybe trying it on a massive
I believe in here Was not the best idea Oh yeah there isn't
any space on the top Attached to Oh no Attached to shelf
There we go Johnny Okay Oh you got him attached Yeah Oh Wait
what Yes!
We have one!
That was like one small spot.
One small spot that would work.
Okay.
He's like our mermaid on a pirate ship, you know.
Oh, beautiful.
He is.
The SS Johnny.
The SS Johnny, that's the car's name now.
Yeah.
Are we too near the lake for me to attempt to drive?
Okay, so Q.
Then I can switch gears.
Okay, so these are gears.
So what do the gears mean?
Oh, real quick, real, real quick.
Dwargo, thank you so much for 50 gears!
They're very cute!
Thank you!
Wait!
We appear to be going backwards.
We start at one.
Oh, are we in reverse?
I don't know.
Just press forward.
Let's go to one.
One, and then you press forward, you press W to go forward.
And then, as you go faster and faster, you slowly gear up to
two, three, four, five.
W.
Toggle engine?
No, is that something else?
Are you...
Oh, there you go, there you go.
Yeah.
Okay.
Toggle press clutch.
What is a clutch?
Oh, that's the...
Okay, that's the thing.
Toggle Park Toggle Lights Exit Vehicle Okay I think I get it
guys I think I get it Okay Okay At a slow speed you'll only
ever be in one But if you're ramping up like what you're
gonna do down the hill Then you would go to all the
different gears Oh good job You're on the thing You're on
the thing Park Park I parked Alright Then we're driving To
Do the...
Thing.
Oh my god!
I did it!
Good job!
Oh my gosh!
You did it!
Oh, my bad.
There you go.
And you can...
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Do-do-do-do-do-do.
All right.
Togo engine.
No, that's off.
Oh, my bad.
Yeah!
Do it.
Oh, that's in park.
No, we don't want park.
No, Toggle Park.
I want to be in this thing.
Yeah, we're going.
We're going.
Yeah, I see you driving away.
No!
Yeah!
Yes!
Oh, I tripped shot a grill through the door while you were
driving.
Everyone saw it.
Everyone saw it and clapped.
Right, tripped.
Is this the right way?
Yeah.
Yep.
Keep on going.
Is gear one good?
I think so.
What?
Yeah.
I think you can just do this whole hill in gear one.
Basically, from my understanding, the gears, when you go up,
they get looser, no?
Or do they get tighter?
Okay.
Ugh.
What does loose and tight mean?
I'm when I ride my bike When I would ride my bike And I
would change the gear It would be tighter Can change the
gear on a bike?
Yeah!
Do you ride a bike?
No, that's fine No, I also didn't ride a bike For a very
long time I don't think I learned until I was 14 Oh gosh,
you were so far away Oh
Oh my god.
That might have been a bit of the ban.
But we're good.
Yeah, yeah.
It fell down a cliff.
Don't worry.
Oh, that's the whole back of the van.
It's okay.
It's like a Jeep now.
It's like a Jeep.
Who are you guys?
I think that's trendy.
Yeah.
Usually.
I like how we're just chasing after it.
Fifi, we're not even...
Okay.
Oh, you might have lost a little bit more, but that's okay.
follow me oh oh yeah yeah yeah oh wait don't follow me
actually i'm going in wait um actually don't uh there the
road is actually over here i don't know why i can't move oh
keep going forward
driving driving stick is driving stick is the bane of many
people's existence did you guys hear johnny when we died did
you guys hear him every time
Okay, guys, well, I'm not sure I should be driving, but I
did my best.
You did such a good job, actually.
Yeah, no, I did so much better than last time.
Yeah.
We'll do more driving lessons every now and then when we get
to safe places.
Thanks, guys.
I appreciate it.
Okay.
And then you'll be a pro.
You're getting there.
Oh, I got to toggle the engine.
music damn yeah wow it's so wait it's kind of stressing me
out it's so like dramatic oh my god someone's got it oh yeah
oh the mooses in the club yeah oh the mooses in the club
here let me show you my pov what i see oh you have to you
have to like turn the crank yeah yeah but you have to
What?
Okay, I should probably stop that because chat's gonna be
like, Vicky, stop vibing so much.
Here, here, let me show you what you see.
Let me show you what you see.
Or what I see.
Oh yeah.
Give me the moose.
Yeah.
You need the moose.
Okay, yeah.
Can't drop here.
Oh, never mind.
Okay.
That's okay.
You can...
Oh.
No.
Keep... keep...
Keep...
You have to hold it.
You have to hold it the whole time.
Relax.
Okay.
Yeah.
You hear that, Tenchi?
Relax.
All right.
Are you safe on land now?
Yeah.
Yes, you are.
You are safe on land.
I'm safe on the go.
I'm going for it.
I'm just going for it.
Yes.
Do it.
Oh, dear.
Never mind.
No.
Oh, moose, actually.
Oh, moose.
Um, I'm stuck a little.
Oh.
I can't get up the hill.
Oh, I would say go to your right a little bit.
Try to go to the right a little bit.
Maybe unless you're stuck.
They're just getting so lucky.
They're getting so much strength.
Oh, there we go!
Oh, hippie!
Wait!
Go, you can do it!
how do I oh who says hog hey push me push me okay I'm gonna
push as well okay yeah come here hey hey okay okay okay okay
okay okay I'm gonna have to drop the moose oh where am I
what the heck is happening right now can't drop it let me on
the moose.
I need to get a beer.
Let me try it.
Let me try reversing.
Yeah, try reversing.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Am I stuck?
What are you stuck on is the question?
I don't know.
I was just driving up the hill.
I don't see what you're stuck on.
Oh, wait.
We do have the wedge thingies, right?
We have the the wenches.
Oh, the wedge.
Um, we have one.
One might have fallen out um during um driving no it's okay
we can use oh wait there's one right we gotta pick up this
one and then we gotta bring it up here right oh yeah the
front one right the front yeah we can just pull it up the
hill right oh i think so hold on let me grab yeah then for a
pull it here yeah yeah yeah okay okay and then we have the
control I'm gonna go get a beer so I can do a bit of
pushing.
How do we get inside?
Oh, you got in?
Nice, nice.
Got in.
Are you in?
All right.
Winch me.
Nice.
Is it working?
It's working!
Yippee!
Nice!
I think you'll have to drive though once it gets to the top.
Or else it'll fall back down.
Oh, wait.
I need to unwench it.
Hold on.
Unwench.
I can do that.
Yeah, if you could.
Okay.
Got it.
Now you are unwenched.
You have no bit.
Oh, you.
Yippee.
Oh.
The pole is right there.
I don't know how to get rid of it, though.
Just be careful of it.
Yeah, there you go.
Woo-hoo!
Nice.
Nice!
Wait, what are we winched to on the bottom?
Hold on, wait, wait, the back one is winched for some
reason.
Okay, there you go.
All good?
Are we good?
Yep, we're good.
Okay!
You guys want to come, do you want to come inside or you
want to stay outside?
I'll come in.
I'll come here's wheel.
Oh my gosh, the winch pole was stabbing me through the
driver's seat.
Okay, that's fine.
Look at this POV of the moose.
Wait.
There he is.
Go Phoebe.
So I've attempted the hill.
Vicky has somewhat attempted the hill.
Phoebe, it's your turn now.
Is it time?
It's time.
You can do it, I believe, actually.
You're good at this.
I'll try.
I don't know if I'm good at it necessarily, but...
i think there's gonna be a bear up here i'm feeling a bear
i'm scared your bear sensors are are tingling yeah i think
kumamon's gonna be here
this is way better than that rave music we've got our own
we've got our own jukebox i love it yeah we don't we don't
need we don't need those uh cassettes Yeah!
We've got a bar here.
There might be a mine in the grass.
And there might be a bear in the woods.
I almost thought you said there was a mime in the grass.
I was like, oh, scary!
A mine!
Oh, dead.
I told you.
Oh, there's a bear spray right here.
There's a bear spray.
Whoa!
Do they know if I spray him?
Does it kill him or does it kill him?
doesn't deter him oh save you guys like that i'm leading him
away i'm leading him away make him turn around oh i've i
sprayed i put the
i'm leading him to the mine whoa it didn't kill him and i'm
dead wait no i'm not dead okay i'm breaking off the cliff
vicky i'm gonna distract him okay i'm gonna lead him to the
other mine if i can find where it is hello i don't think get
worse oh no oh he's running i'm he's running can someone
come pick me up yeah where is he running to you're over here
he's gone i'm i'm actually off the cliff if you um look over
the cliff yeah i'm scared to move i'm trying to find where
do you see me let me know you see me oh i see you hey hi hi
okay pick up up thank you nice actually i didn't get that
injured from that oh good and he ran like the coward he is
yeah yeah he saw our moose and he was thoroughly intimidated
i wonder if you can cook the bears as well seems to reason
that you probably can we could probably throw a grill at
them wait we can probably oh wait no there's one more mine
as there by the uh-oh oh oh i hear i heard some growling
wait you heard it i heard some growling in my ear coming
into the car i'm all the way behind the oh i'm far away i
know it's fine i'm gonna i'm gonna go ahead i'm going to i i
see the mines i'm gonna set off all the mines okay he
doesn't come back by then wait i can set them off with the
plank i forgot ah nice oops i missed oh wait i didn't miss
it just um covered it wait it's like right underneath there
how did i do that wait maybe i need to drop it not as
perfectly as i did watch out oh what how am i so good at
this oh my gosh i should be a professional plank layer
Watch out, Vicky!
Vicky, wait!
Oh, oh.
Oh, yeah, watch out.
I see.
Nice!
That was perfect!
Yeah, sure.
That one over there is still there?
Uh, there is the one, yeah.
The one that's like on the road.
I don't like it.
Which one?
Stairs menacingly.
I think that, there.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, watch out.
Oh, nice.
I don't know why it's scary.
No, we are all good.
Yippee!
Perfect shot from Phoebe Chanchebe there.
Very good.
Vicky, could you please take this back over to where mental
is?
Of course I can.
And then I'll bring the car.
Yes.
Thank you.
Okay, here we go.
Minto!
Are you ready to walk the plank?
Wait, do you want to jowse with our planks?
Okay, can we do that?
Can we jowse?
All I see are two very long sticks.
It's like many times!
I'm so excited!
Oh, no, no!
Okay, so we drop it.
Okay, I got it, I got it, okay, okay.
Okay, let's do it again.
I understand the assignment now.
Okay, all right.
All right, all right.
Ready?
This is beautiful.
Oh.
No!
Whoa!
That was the fetus!
Whoa, is it on my head?
Wait, hold up.
Is it on my head?
Wait, wait, wait.
I want to keep this on your head.
Wait, look at this, guys.
Wait, can I climb this?
I can climb your head!
You can!
Wait, Phoebe, how does this look from your POV?
It's amazing.
Here, I'm going to screenshot it.
Why is it so rocky?
Wait, Phoebe, come from the side.
How does it look with, like, me underneath it?
And then mint climb.
Oh, no!
No!
It's okay.
All right, what we do with these?
Laticing.
Laticing like a pie.
I wonder if we don't lattice.
Because the lattice made it so that I couldn't move last
time.
So maybe...
Oh, actually, yeah.
Maybe not lattice.
Maybe it's this easy.
Do we need another one?
I feel like it's going to be not flat if I put another one
down.
Right.
Maybe...
Let me try putting them closer together and then we could
fit it.
Hold on.
You can fit it.
Okay.
There you go.
Ah, here.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Yes.
Beautiful.
Be- Um, so close.
Um.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I like that.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'll move this one over.
There we go.
There you go.
Perfect room.
Oh, so close.
Just give it a little shove with your toes.
I clearly don't have those plank kills.
I got it!
There you go, you did it!
I did it!
It worked out!
I do do my daily planks, but not that kind of plank,
unfortunately.
You're doing better than me.
Alright, I'm ready to press the button when you need me.
Okay.
Oops, I pressed it early.
Okay, it's done.
tell me when i'm far enough in uh in a little more in a
little more all right you're going up oh never mind uh come
back down oh i don't know what happened there actually i'm
gonna try again
oh it looks like it's going up yeah it's too noisy i hide
our moment Going up.
You okay?
Now I'm meowing.
What I did last time?
Oh, good.
Are you okay?
You're live.
Yeah, I'm going around here.
I will come retrieve you.
Oh no, it's okay.
I think I see the slope.
Yes.
And not a bear inside.
Wait, guys, should I try the jump- Jump King thing again?
Or is it?
This way.
I'm here!
The Jump King thing!
Hello!
Check out the house real quick.
What we got?
Are we got more burgers and scraps?
scrap is everything good what happened um are you attempting
the jump killing um um um um you got this you got this um
you got this uh i if what i've got is a death then yeah i've
got this uh are you dead are you dead uh Oh yeah Huh Where
are you?
Where are you?
Oh I see you down there I got you I'll come get you Oh thank
you Thank you so much It seems to be Some scrap metal down
here as well So that's at least something Oh it is the jump
king thing Ouch I have several broken bow Oh are you dead
dead?
Oh you are Oh, thanks.
I'll just eat some Nuggies right here.
Is there a way to get back up?
That's a cassette down here.
Probably.
There must be.
If there's a way to get down, there has to be a way to get
up.
No.
Yeah.
There's gotta be.
Maybe it works like that, perhaps.
What comes down must go up.
Probably.
What comes up must go down.
Yeah, my feet don't.
Sorry.
No, it's a grand.
um okay oh yeah i think you just i think you just keep going
on the rocks until you get to a like i've managed to climb
over here somehow okay but now i'm not sure where to go from
here hello hello hello bit you can go up a tiny bit further
wait a second vicky yeah Thank you.
Oh man, don't!
Can you come up a tiny bit, tiny, tiny bit?
Someone grab me!
Grab me!
Try and try.
It won't let me aim like this.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, wait, okay, wait, wait.
We're nearly there.
Do it again, do it again.
Nearly there.
E, E, pick up.
E.
Keep going, keep doing that.
E, pick up, E.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Phoebe, you just, you realize what you Oh, um...
Oh, um...
Okay, guys, I'm gonna try and save you both.
Alright, I'm up here.
What do you mean to save us both?
Oh.
Hi.
Phoebe, no!
You know...
Phoebe!
I'm gonna look around.
Maybe...
Phoebe, I feel like this was the way to get back up over
here.
I think so, too.
Yeah.
Yeah, probably.
you know what I think if Vicky becomes the jump king then
then you'll be able to get back up yeah you think okay all
right try to try to become the jump king and I'll just yeah
yeah here come here come out for me I'll try and get you to
but we really need the jump king because because we need
that watermelon hat desperately don't we desperately oh wait
we're around the other side okay I'm like spamming ear It
says I can pick you up, but that's not what we want.
I know, I know.
You see him so much.
Wait, wait, wait.
I had it for like two seconds.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
I'm spamming.
Okay.
I need it.
I need it to hand keyboard this.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
You got this jump queen!
What is going on down there?
I believe in you!
Oh no!
What do you mean oh no?
Is she good?
Turn around.
What is this?
What do you mean?
It was a friend.
Okay, look for anything.
Oh yeah, if I saw anything.
We're all done, Joe.
I'm gonna return, I'm gonna return her body to you.
Oh, nice shot.
Wait, what if I get you from here?
I could try from here.
Yeah, just, like, do a big old toss.
Like, as hard as you can.
Throw her body.
Oh, tank, so close.
Oh, no.
Excuse me.
To be fair, this is all my own doing.
Okay.
I shouldn't have tried to become the jump queen.
No, you are the jump queen.
This is actually a skill issue.
I can feel my left hand carpal tunneling.
Give me a second.
Oh no!
Uh, oh god, I need to hold it down longer.
You're in the rocks.
Okay.
Okay, what I do is I double hand keyboarded.
Okay, right hand on the space bar.
Left hand holding down Q.
Oh, I got her!
Yeah!
Drop, revive, in the butt.
Thanks!
Alright, VB, come try this.
Come try over here.
I might be able to grab you right here.
Alright guys, it's the last time I'm gonna try.
Third time lucky, otherwise we're giving up.
Jump, jump, jump.
I'm getting closer to you.
Jump, jump.
Ah!
I had you!
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Okay, don't go any closer than this though.
Woo!
Yeah!
See
me and my baby?
Vicky?
I want to see where are you oh yeah I can see it's the
circle of life moves the soul
I don't know I don't know the word oh there's a bear spray
here find a place In the circle.
The circle.
Circle of life.
Oh, good.
There is a path.
I believe in you, Jump Queen.
Thanks.
Have more confidence.
Oh my gosh, you're so close.
Oh my god.
It's right in front of you.
It's right there.
That's yours.
It belongs to you.
It's literally right there.
You are the right full air.
Yes!
Scam!
Let it be known here that Vicky was, in fact, the jump
queen.
Wait, that is a scam.
I think this is our last EpiPen, I think.
We won't be able to bring you back after this.
Okay, well, I've got my hat.
That's what we needed.
We needed the lucky hat.
mental yes i think i'm going to go back down one more time
all right i know we'll catch you we did it once yeah we can
do it again we can do it again no that was such a scam guys
not gonna lie i i got that melon fair and square oh yeah you
can have it i mean you guys have saved me enough that you
deserve it thanks okay well we'll come back for the hat in a
bit let's just make sure No, I'm in.
It's okay.
You prioritize the hat.
No, no, no.
You take that hat.
No, I'm not gonna take it.
I'm not gonna take your hat.
Please take the hat.
No, I'm not gonna take your hat.
Don't leave the hat in the...
in the abyss.
Oh, oh, wait.
Whoa.
Oh, we're both down here?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oops.
Ouch.
I might die.
yeah i'm on the top i'm on the top vicky is saved um oh wait
um i just put down the hat and
it cooked you it was me it was me
the hat where is vicky why does it say vicky's name tag is
inside of the rock no no it's okay i'm she no no i'm good
i'm fine i'm fine i'm on the grass i'm good I'm chilling.
Okay, for some reason.
Oh, I see it, too.
I'm seeing your name tag in the rocks.
Yeah, me too.
No, don't worry, don't worry.
I'm good.
Okay, can you grab me?
Mm-hmm.
It's E, right?
E.
Yeah.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, there she is.
Yeah, there she is.
Hi.
Where is the hat?
I dropped it and it clipped through the rock.
I guess we can't have nice things.
No, it's okay, Min.
It's okay.
You know, the real important thing is we've got to each
other guys okay we made it out of there and you know you
prove yourself you are yeah you are the jump queen oh thanks
guys thanks i appreciate it oh well that was an adventure
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry for you friendship
friendship's the real treasure i found a cassette tip
Let's take that with us.
Maybe it spawned in the truck, maybe, in the RV.
Yeah, maybe.
We can hope and pray.
How do we get back to the truck this way?
Yeah, this way.
Then we have to go around the whole thing.
You're sure you saw it, right?
The hat.
Yeah, you sure you saw it.
There was a hat there, right?
Yeah.
What?
You guys telling me that I made the hat up.
I don't know.
I mean, it could have just been a really colorful rock.
is all i'm just saying guys that was a watermelon hat a
hundred percent chat did you see a watermelon hat yeah might
have been a mirage have you how how many cans of beer have
you had oh my gosh you guys uh how are you gaslighting me
like this yeah it is a warm day today you know the illusions
are you know it would not be unusual for you I have video
evidence of this stream that there is a watermelon hat chat
did you see a watermelon hat did you see one one for yes two
for no yeah three for I believe in the ultimate almighty
watermelon thank you so much four for Johnny I'm seeing only
twos only twos three yeah three three three five six stroke
and concussion yeah yeah
okay are we all here yeah we've got a cassette can we play
it yeah sure how do i put it in oh insert i don't know i no
experience oh oh we're on the move we're on the move that
way it's the big jump isn't it yeah it's the big jump coming
up oh yep wow epic music for the jump i know this is awesome
yo go go go go go go go you got this baby go go go go go go
go go go go yeah yeah yeah switch to two maybe i don't know
okay round two don't stop holding it down one three don't
stop holding down the yeah keep four one four why did i why
am i dead dying why oh gosh wait i think i'm flipping out
five oh
hi johnny well that was wait what happened
I didn't feel like it didn't look like it was straight.
What happened, everybody?
Shall we review the footage?
Review the evidence.
I gotta be real with you.
I could barely see over the wheel.
And I don't know if that's a skill issue.
Or if I was just...
I have to use pillows when I drive, okay?
I have to sit on.
Why aren't cars made with consideration the shorter people,
huh?
I feel this is discrimination against everybody who is
short.
Just driving this RV.
I think, I don't know, guys, if we're ever going to get past
this part.
All right.
Well, why?
I think we can.
We were almost there.
Actually, we got further the very first time we tried it six
months ago.
Yeah.
Sure, people are always saying they're being discriminated.
But what about doors and tools?
people always hit my head on the door frame guys you know
that's that's discrimination heard that sometimes
countertops and such are too short I'm yeah like my sink in
Japan is so low I think we can speed run this I think so too
okay we're ready gonna get out I'm gonna I'm gonna get out
to do the thing thing all right yeah we'll speed run this
i'll try not to get stuck on the uh the thing this time wait
i have a question since you're about the same height as me
have you do you also use a pillow when you drive i don't but
i scoop my seat all the way forward and i told that that's
not good is that not good i've been told that okay what i
probably what's could I probably should use a pillow now
that I think about it but I worry about my booty the
pillow's comfy it is wait are we good now oh oh oh sorry
sorry no it's okay when I turn to when I turn to look at you
then it's oh yeah yeah I know it's annoying all right we're
good all right I'm going I'm going everybody in everybody
buckled you worry about your booty what yeah won't the
pillow make your booty like softer no is that how it works
oh maybe yeah maybe it would work protect your booty guys
protect your booty everybody it's very important yeah my
booty is like my best asset i'd say so i worry about it yeah
i mean all of den said to right i think we we would all
agree it's probably all collective best ass yeah yeah yeah
cake.exe yeah going slow and steady everybody okay you got
this you got this yeah all right okay now go to the left a
little yeah we're going good we're going up up up it's our
moment it's our moment you know together we're golden gonna
be gonna be golden am i breaking the rv oh a little bit but
it's fine it's fine yeah just just fix it i got a lot of
actually no it's very intact no you're good oh gosh wait
hard right there we go nice what if i go over the mine do
you think it'll be all right test that or only one way all
in favor of going over the mine yes say say um i'm gonna i'm
gonna raise you and see if i can disarm the mines before you
can carry out that plan we probably should go to the house
anyway oh yeah um okay you guys go to the house i'll disarm
the mines okay thank
Yep.
Alive.
We're good.
I'm good.
I got another Epi pen for when...
Wait, I got an antidote.
Wait, there's so much good stuff in the house today.
Does it change up?
Oh, yeah.
The antidote wasn't that cool.
Oh.
Are you good?
I'm good.
Oh.
Yeah, there's another Epi pen.
Probably won that.
Yeah.
The antidote.
I don't know.
Take the bear spray for sure.
Did you get the second?
mines oh it's right here wait wait baby here here here it's
in the grass it's in the grass in the grass oh i see i see i
see i'm behind right here it's right here aha that's the one
i ran into earlier okay bear spray oh so close there we go
oh oops uh so close little to your left Oh, very good.
Yep, yep.
Cool.
All right, I will continue driving.
Did we get everything in the house?
No, I'm still collecting.
There's motor oil, there's still beer.
I'm taking the antidote back to the van as well.
I'll take the beer, the most important part.
A balanced breakfast.
The happy pan.
Happy, happy, happy.
I parked in a tree.
I sing that song in my bunny.
Actually, I'll just keep going.
When it's snap time.
It's like, oh.
It's like, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh.
She's giving me a look.
I shouldn't have done that.
Oh no.
It's like food, food now for me?
Food time.
Wait, so cats have like a churu.
Do bunnies have anything similar?
To a churu.
I saw like in Japan they have like bunny churros.
No way.
We should get some next time.
We should.
I haven't been able to find them myself yet.
We'll go, we'll find some.
You can sing that at karaoke with the video, you know?
What?
Yeah.
Really?
Ayami Mama, you know like that syrup that's good for your
throat?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
She calls them Ningen no Chudu.
That's so cute.
It is Ningen no Chudu.
I'm also Ningen no choo-do.
For people who don't know, it means like human choo-do.
It's human choo-do.
Are we good to go?
I'm gonna do that every time I have it now.
Yeah, human choo-do.
It looks pretty planked up.
Yeah, I think we're good.
Okay.
Here I go.
Here we go.
Okay.
A tiny bit more.
am i good is it a little little tiny bit more okay you're
good you're good okay i say you're all right man okay we're
good nice here i go yepy yeah nicely done i'll get us to the
top the tippy tippy tippy tippy tippy okay oh yeah non-cat
owners chudus are like a liquid snack for cats in like a
long plastic tube they love it oh my god they go insane for
it seriously like you'll have cats that actually like go
feral they revert to primal senses when they see a chudu and
they're like this is what they do They do and it makes me
curious.
I'm like is it that good?
Is it really truly that good?
I think we have to try it.
Is it safe?
Yeah, is it safe to eat?
Probably right.
It must be.
I bet it's really fishy.
I want to be in tune with my cat.
Yeah.
Unless it's fishy.
It still could be good.
They have different flavors of churro I think.
So if you want chicken.
You can get chicken.
The tuna ones smell nice.
Maybe that's where we gotta have is the tuna one.
Yeah, maybe.
Maybe.
Delish.
I don't need to go again, do I?
No, we're gonna go.
We're gonna go over the thing.
One of us, too.
We'll go.
Are you sure you don't wanna try?
Why don't you guys try?
You guys can do it.
I believe in you.
Well, actually, no, I don't trust myself.
I don't trust myself.
Do you guys trust me?
Do you trust me?
Yeah.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
You did it once before.
Oh, whoa.
It's fine.
I'm not dead.
Oh, thank goodness.
Shining, shimmering.
Splendid.
Tell me, princess.
Huh, I'm under the thing.
I'm under the thing.
Yeah.
Yeah, I see.
Is that a bear?
Oh, there you are.
Where?
A bear?
I thought I heard.
I thought I heard a growl.
maybe not maybe it was my tummy i feel like jumping from the
from the middle as much of the middle as you can is the key
oh yeah right oh it's
fine we have so many epi pens i'll just keep bringing you
back i don't know how they're supposed to revive you from
being dead but last time i did it I died this time like five
times.
Yeah.
So sad.
Oh, you got her.
You got her.
Thank you.
How did you get down there so fast?
I don't know.
Throw the ball.
Just so used to this chasm now, I guess.
Beg.
Beg to be revived.
Oh.
Please.
Oh, please, Minto.
Oh, please.
Revive me.
I have.
What can I...
provide to oh okay i was oh okay i didn't even need to bring
out the snake ocelot dojin that i had in my pocket i was
gonna offer you i'll take it yeah yeah chibi chibi you want
to jump yes i would like to jump okay i'm gonna do the you
can do it two hands again yippee easy oh i see we're good at
this now we're we're too good at this now i know we're like
so experienced If I take literally any more damage, I think
I will die.
Uh-uh.
Wait, how did you take so much damage?
What happened?
Um, yeah.
I fell back down when I was throwing Vicky up.
And then I broke a bone.
Oh!
Thanks for breaking the bone for me.
Yeah, I kind of shattered both my kneecaps and shin spree.
But it's okay.
Wow.
Oh my gosh, how are you doing?
They will roll back.
It's through sheer willpower.
it's that point where you can't feel the pain anymore yeah i
get it all right do we want to attempt the the ramp oh my
gosh it's scary this one two of us who will do it what do
you feel like i like i like how i've just been discounted
from the start yeah who has gotten closer that's a good
that's a good point also yeah maybe i only did it the one
time i've done it now twice I think repairing was six months
ago though.
I don't think repairing is going to do anything.
Oh, well, I guess I can reach the other side.
If we die, we die.
But we can repair and then maybe if we get to the other
side, it's not so busted.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Oh, yeah.
Minto, can you sit in the passenger seat?
Uh-huh.
And tell me if I'm not straight.
Oh.
I can't see the road.
maybe if I stand in the passenger seat oh can you see it now
I'm gonna get on top of the van hold on I'm gonna that's the
problem oh yeah Vicky you can scream from the top of the van
that's what I'm thinking yeah yeah it definitely maybe we
should have said something because I oh sorry sorry excuse
me I'm trying to I'm repairing here I'm repairing here okay
I'm in my I'm in my seat ready to go Almost ready.
That's as good as...
Chat calling me out.
Wait, what are they saying?
Phoebe is definitely not straight.
Oh, I see.
I know, okay?
We all know.
Okay.
Yeah, I definitely saw you.
I thought it was like a little quirk of yours that you were
doing when you were driving all over the place last time.
So I didn't say anything.
Just to be quirky, just driving, swerving everywhere.
Yeah, but you seem to have a handle, so...
I'm sure that'll go down really well with the police when
you get called in.
Oh, yeah, just being quirky.
This is my driving quirk.
Please understand.
We're not going to get called into the police because we're
going to be dead.
That works, too.
I mean, if you don't want to do it, Phoebe, I can try, but
I'm scared.
No, I will do it.
I will do it.
I just really, like, scream at me if I'm not...
You can do it if I'm not driving straight.
I'll just go straight, straight!
Or do you want me to say to your left?
Okay, I got the acceleration down.
Okay, I'll try to stay to the left.
Okay.
Will I stay on the van?
We'll find out.
Here we go.
Here we go, everyone.
To your right.
Wow.
To my right a little bit.
Yeah, to your right.
You have the view of the century.
Faster, faster, faster, faster, faster.
Oh, I run four now.
Five!
Run five!
Here we go!
I'm yes oh my god park the car oh wait we're stuck in a tree
this is great wow that was so oh my god we made it we made
it but here I'm gonna I'm gonna winch us out of this
situation if I can get inside thank you we did a good job
baby wait we lost the ladder so good okay so cool from my
pov on top of the van it looked sick it was like a roller
coaster yeah really good yeah okay all right is anyone still
in the car i'm on the car oh uh toggle rear oh you have the
remote good good good good um i don't know which we need to
push it maybe some pushing i'm gonna go get a bit push it i
don't i don't know if i'm pulling it right push it oh oh i
need to go in by the top okay oh wait oh oh oh the pushing
worked oh wow
it's completely stripped oh my god you're naked you're naked
car you're naked what was the car's name again the ss johnny
the ss johnny's no ss johnny i'm so surprised that it's not
like showing that it's gonna dive sooner than it okay i
cannot get in that way i'm gonna go in oh wait we have very
little health never mind i'm liar oh did i hit somebody
sorry you killed me i did
casualties are bound to happen i'm sorry
oof oof oof hold on Phoebe we'll get you down in no power
yeah just give us a second I'll just be chilling here yeah
yeah yeah you're a bit of a liability maybe so a lot of keep
you out of the way until we're done all right repaired and
ready to go I think at least on the inside just a little bit
more would you like make your case i have an epi pen oh
would you like to make your case for your revival yes i got
us over that jump you did you did do that anything else yeah
anything else um i quit smoking you did i shattered both my
kneecaps and shins for you yeah okay that's fair okay here
you go thank you i'm not convinced we saw that cigarette in
your mouth yeah not too long You better make sure.
That was three lifetimes ago.
Phoebe Chanchebe, if I see another one in your mouth, you
know what's going to happen.
Yeah, yeah.
What's going to happen?
The same fate you just had.
I'll make it happen.
No, murder me?
Whoa!
All right.
We're murdering now?
Oh, maybe.
Can you even murder people in this game?
Oh, yeah, on the hammer, I guess.
What?
She was filming for TikTok.
Yeah.
In fact, it was live.
It was live.
I didn't say it.
Can we not just have a nature holiday in the camper van
without you putting everything on TikTok?
I know.
Sorry, chat.
We, uh, you weren't invited on this trip.
Dang.
Wow.
Look at the ramp from here.
It's crazy.
Whoa.
That's terrifying.
I know.
That is a ramp.
Dang.
I can't.
I don't want to look.
Are we unwinched?
Yeah, we are unwinched.
There ain't no way I can get in that way.
I'm just going to go.
Not unwinched.
Wait, we're close to a garage.
Turn us around.
Yeah, maybe I shouldn't have repaired so much.
Oh, gosh.
Wait, Phoebe.
Oh, okay.
Oh, my God.
Gentle.
If you see me, you've gotten too close.
Okay.
Now I can reverse, right?
Yeah, you can reverse.
Peep.
Other way.
Can I reverse a little more?
Actually, now I'm going to go forward a little bit.
Yeah, yeah.
There you go.
Okay, now I'm going to reverse.
Reverse.
Oh, other way.
Yeah, yeah.
Other way.
There you go.
And now keep turning.
Yep, yep.
This is like the five-point turn.
Yep.
Oh, wow.
There's even wing mirrors in game yep oh my gosh there are
very good very good yeah there's the garage the garage oh
wow they made our graves for us fantastic there's graves
whoa are one of those yours maybe cold drinks oh wait revive
friends i guess if we wanted to revive anyone
um i believe in you is this good enough if i press revive
friends oh nobody comes back yeah i think that's like if we
died somewhere and we couldn't find us you know something
like that yeah cold coffee arcade universe wait this is for
you vicky arcade universe whoa yes well guys look i'm super
speed look at this whoa Whoa!
What?
Whoa!
You're like Sonic!
I'm Sonic!
Woo!
It's like when like a five-year-old is just like, look at
what I can do, Mom!
Oh.
But it's very cool, dear.
Very, very cool.
I'm Sonic, Mom!
I'm Sonic, look!
I'm Sonic!
I love when kids are like, Look what I can do!
And they like flail their arms.
And you just...
Good job, kid.
You're doing a real good job at Flailing Girl.
Oh, thank you, Joyce.
Wait, how do we fix the car?
Good question.
I thought normally we would have...
Yeah, I think you can fix it here.
Is it that thing in the ground?
What's this?
This red thing?
Yeah, that thing helps fix it.
Oh.
So maybe we need to be able to get to it.
Yeah, I can't get under it.
trying to run in okay can you crouch and let me run you over
i'm literally under the wheel oh should i back up can i back
up actually can you go forward go forward okay oh oh oh that
works yeah that worked that worked i got the welding machine
nice whoa that's so cool Yeah.
Yeah.
Night of fire.
Okay.
Nice.
And then whatever the red thing is, I'm not sure what that
is.
I think it's the engine.
Maybe whatever that broken bit on the bomb we've got is.
Maybe it helps with that.
I don't know.
Oh no, sorry.
Sorry.
That's my own health.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, below the bad, is that our combined health?
Is that how it works?
No.
What is that?
So you see we've got the green thing with the shield, and
then we've got like the other bar below it.
What is that?
I think that's like the overall integrity, and then the
green bar is our, like, is the, like if we lose the shield,
like the, the door and the stuff around the RV.
Ah, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah.
Like, how do we repair whatever that is?
I don't know.
I thought it was like in the, like the, it looks like the
engine line.
When my car says check engine.
Or transmission.
Actually, I don't know what's the difference.
Oh, there's a, hold on.
There's a motor oil right here.
Maybe that'll do something.
Yeah.
I tried to fix it earlier.
I couldn't figure it out.
From the, wait.
In oil under the.
bed they're ignoring us chat what no we're not red is engine
oil yeah but where's the how do you i have the oil but i
don't see and i'm under the bed but i don't see i'm gonna
reverse a little bit so that we can i'm just gonna join you
guys in here see what's going on the engine is under the how
do you oh we literally lift up the bed oh the bed bed like
the bed Inside like a sleeping bag.
Put it again, please.
I'm no stuck under the...
Oh, I have... I'm fixing it.
Wait.
I fixed it!
Yay!
Nice!
Alright.
Sorry, who I ran over?
It's okay.
Hi.
Hello.
Nice job, guys.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, sorry.
Can I get in the van?
Okay.
Oh, no, I can't.
Hold on.
There we go.
There we are.
Yeah!
Oh, it was so easy this whole time.
Are we winched onto something?
Why does it have that red lock?
I don't know.
I saw that too.
Nice.
That is confusing.
Oh, I fixed it.
Okay.
Just kidding.
Oh, what was it?
I don't know.
there's so much stuff under the bed i never knew before good
job guys oh my god we are at a hundred percent health
everything wow wow wow wow all right there's space for this
shall we shall we continue
Shut up and drive.
Hello.
Oh, I like this.
I like this tune.
Wait, this is kind of risky.
Okay, this is a little...
Just a little bit.
I'm just gonna go for it.
Yeah, go for it.
Wow.
Nice.
You're doing good.
Thanks.
I like this.
This song is nice.
brand new territory says chat oh this is giving proper
proper road trip vibes oh geez uh wait i can go wait i think
there's two ways we can go here next exit 65.
oh wait 66.
yeah there's like an up ramp and then there's a other one
what's up here I don't know.
I'm going to run to it because it looks like a dead end,
maybe.
Does it?
I don't know.
Actually, no.
It might just be a different way.
A different route, maybe?
I would have to like...
I would have to like turn it all around.
I could look at the map.
Yeah, the map!
There's a map?
I don't know where it is.
Tell us which way to go.
It's over here.
Oh, where?
Oh, it's on the side of the passenger seat.
Okay.
a map oh yes road atlas okay yeah yeah yeah right where are
we going where are we going okay um uh uh I how are we meant
to know where we're going I think forward um the compass of
your heart yeah like we can go forward um around the around
the chasm.
I don't think there's any reason not to do that.
Forward sounds good.
Yeah, like keep following the road along that we're going at
now.
Oh, but then that'll lead us back eventually.
Hmm.
Or we go up into the mountain.
What do we think, guys?
Where should we go?
Does your heart tell you to go straight?
Do you guys want to have a look?
I think we can keep going around the chasm if we want to.
And then there's another...
And then there's a road that goes up left, I think.
So we keep going around the chasm.
And then we go left.
Oh, yeah, look.
Look, it climbs over there.
Oh, this is a bit scary.
Wow.
Just around the riverbend.
Oh, what was that?
I look right so much.
Just around the river, beyond the shore.
Somewhere past the sea.
I don't know what for.
Oh,
this is a tight turn.
Copyright Pokemon.
Oh, that is tight.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
I'm gonna get out.
Wait, we should get ready to push.
You can, in fact, back up.
You have space to back up.
Yeah, but the vehicle does not allow.
I think someone needs to push me.
I wonder where he's stuck.
Need a little push.
Is that a...
Like, push from the front?
Yeah, from the front.
Yeah, just a little bit more.
Yeah, so close.
Yeah, one good one.
Do I need to give you like a beer push?
Maybe, maybe.
Okay, I'm going to go in.
Okay, I've quit smoking, but it's okay if I take a beer this
one time, right?
Just one time.
Just once, Missy.
I'm at one, too.
Going down to pub, baby.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh,
so close.
Why can't I move?
Oh.
Okay.
I think I'm going to try moving forward this time.
Oh.
Go forward.
I'm going up the wall.
You did a wheelie.
Wow.
I was just showing off my sick skills.
You guys back in.
That was so sick.
That was super good.
Oh, no.
I'm not back in yet.
No.
I'm gonna get on top of the van.
I'll go really slow.
Oh, no.
Okay, I'm gonna floor it now.
I'm flooring it.
I think we're just running.
That's okay.
Are you guys in?
I'm not.
No, we're not.
Okay, I'll go even slow.
I'll go slow.
I'm just too short to...
I'm just trying to jump on the stairs.
Yes, I made it.
Ah, we're in.
You made it?
We're in?
Okay.
All right.
Bajal, Bajal?
I think, is this a different way we went to the last time?
I think it might be.
We've never been this far.
Wow.
Yeah, and we're in new, actual new area, everybody.
Wait a second.
What's this to the left?
Is this anything?
Never mind.
I'm going to go check.
Oh, wait.
No, no, no.
You want to check?
Oh, I'm gonna check.
Okay, I'll park.
I'm an adventurer, and I adventure and I explore.
Oh, there are parts.
There are some scrap parts.
Oh, we could actually use that, actually.
Yeah.
Vicky, do you want to drive?
That was about it.
I can attempt.
Okay, let me put the map back.
This might be a safe place for practice.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to go up.
I'm going up.
Okay, Vicky, you got this.
You can even stay on one.
Press the clutch.
Stay on one.
Stay on one, yeah, just.
In Toggle Park.
In...
Okay.
Yeah, nice.
I'm scoping the area, and there's no bears.
Oh, thank you so much for letting us know.
Oh, my God.
You guys said this was safe.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
Thread the needle.
Oh, that was the needle.
Fred the needle.
Oh, nice.
You did it.
Okay, now I'm a bandit, and I'm going to jump on you from
the top, okay?
Oh, is it part of the practice?
Huh?
Yeah, it's part of the...
It's part of the practice.
That is not happening!
Driving test!
I'm going to...
I'm a bandit.
I'm coming to steal your car.
Oh, my God.
Everybody out!
I have a good!
Uh...
Gale me, come!
I'll shank you bro Oh my god There's a bear There's bear
spray I got the bear spray I got the bear spray Okay Should
I just keep driving Wait we could have driven away From the
bear You didn't have to Oh but he was destroying our car I
killed him Oh Thank you Wait This is a little Oh This is a
little Oof Um How are you supposed to do this Wait Wait
Don't drive it Oh Oh I think we can winch it.
We can winch it, right?
Probably.
Okay.
Maybe?
I think so.
Yeah, yeah.
There's things here.
There's poles.
Ah, meant for winching.
I think I hear...
I think we can winch it to this point first.
If you want to put a winch thing down here-ish.
There's a lot of snakes.
Maybe?
I hear them.
What a thrill.
Oh.
Are they...
solid no that's actually not oh Phoebe that's that's not
Phoebe here do you think we go higher I think we could but
I'm like thinking that it starts to curve right here right
so should we winch to this point and then winch up again
maybe maybe okay I'll put it here okay I'm ready to drive
whenever
I don't think you have to drive.
Oh, okay.
I'll found the wheel just in case we need to suddenly do
something.
Actually, that's a good...
Yeah, if you need to turn or...
Oh, yeah, you might have to turn.
Yeah, you might have to turn.
Okay.
Toggle.
Okay, there.
Should I put another one up here?
Ready?
Yeah.
I don't want to waste it, but...
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I seem to be going a bit oh no it's fine it's fine it's all
good wench wench okay oh no park park park p okay i'm on p
okay i'm on p okay okay now we're gonna i need to put this
down uh here that is yours wait is the wench pole gonna be
in the way?
I'm going to see if I can...
We'll see, I guess.
I don't think...
Yeah, I don't think you can grab it.
Okay, I'm ready.
Just steer to your left.
To the left.
I can still expect steering now.
Yeah.
Okay.
And then once you're past the poles, go to the right.
Oh, oh, the pole is fine.
Never mind, it's not fine.
Everything's fine.
Everything's good?
Yep, everything's fine.
I guess it's fine.
I think it's fine.
Nice.
Wow.
Smooth though.
Okay, park, park, park, park, park.
No, it's so smooth.
It's so smooth right now.
Smooth.
Are you parked?
Yes, I'm not gonna say smooth again.
Oh, I am in park, I'm in park.
I'm in park.
I'm in park!
This is fine.
This is what we want to win for.
Wait, we can use another one.
We can use a further away one, too.
Yeah, I guess use a further away one.
Here, I'll put it, like, right here.
Someone yelled at me.
You were not...
Guys, I was in park!
I was definitely in park.
I was in the park.
I believe you.
You were in park.
Gravity was just too strong.
Yeah.
It was too strong.
Here we come.
Here we go.
Yeah, see, it's all fine.
It doesn't even matter.
Yay!
You might want to steer to the left, though.
Steer to the left.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm steering.
Oh, this is a bit of a situation, maybe.
Oh, there's a snake trying to attack.
Oh, he's right there.
He's like, ah!
I'm dying.
Oh, no.
Oh, there's an ant, there's a, there's a, what's it called?
Antidote thingy in the, in the van.
Yeah, there's an antidote in the, in the van.
There is.
Okay.
Yes, yes, go in.
Use it on yourself.
Yeah, I'm dying.
I don't know.
Yeah, look at me, go.
Oh, that's a snake.
Yeah, that's a snake right there.
He's, like, humping the ground.
He is humping the ground.
Okay.
He's doing exactly what I said.
Nice.
Oh, I'm still poisoned.
It takes more than one antidote.
That's curious.
Okay.
I would like to switch with you real quick, Vicky, if that's
okay.
Yes.
Sit vehicle.
And then, if you could...
What is that snake doing?
I told you!
I don't want you to do that.
Wait, I think...
Wait, I'm trapped on Phoebe.
I can't move.
Oh, my bad.
Thank you, sorry.
I mean, I don't mind, but thank you.
I think this way would be the easiest way.
Okay.
Probably?
Just going straight?
Yeah.
It's a little.
It's a little tie.
But...
I'm showing chat and nature documentary.
Could someone...
And this is a snake.
Yes.
Doing questionable things to the ground.
When it's time to...
Ahu!
What does that mean?
What does it...
When it's time to...
Ahu!
What does that mean?
I need to be unwinched, I think, at some point.
Oh.
But not now.
The snake has mistaken a rock for a snake mate and seems to
be...
It seems lonely.
Yeah.
Okay, let's leave the snake to some...
Listen, let's leave the snake to some privacy, shall we?
Yes.
Okay.
I'm in full view.
I'm watching Mother Nature happen.
Yeah.
Wow, Minto.
Minto, it might suddenly move and just kill you, you know.
Be careful.
I don't think so.
I think he's busy.
Oh, yeah.
That's one way to put it, I suppose.
Wait, what happens if I do...
This.
What was that?
It sounded like a come at me, bro.
Okay.
Okay, why don't you guys see how close you can get to the
snake before it breaks it out of its pattern.
Oh, okay.
Wow.
Oh, am I dead?
Wait, am I dead?
Oh, I'm dead.
Not anymore.
Yay!
Okay, we're fine.
Yay.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
Wait, maybe I can kill him with the plank.
Yeah, kill him.
That did not work.
Oh, it didn't work.
He jumped.
He's a jumper.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I think I'm killing him.
Wait, I think I killed him for real.
No, I didn't.
No, he's definitely still there.
Oh!
Oops.
That's fine.
We can just keep going.
Bye.
We're going to run him over.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Let me know when you want me to unbunch you.
Or am I.
my gosh where am i okay you can unwinch whenever cool this
is not where i intended to be today right okay where'd you
go i i have no idea there's a snake here as well there is a
snake yeah and it's pretty um oh you guys are all over down
there he's feisty he's feisty did you get bit no not yet but
i will soon i can hear him i'm trying to find a way back up.
Okay, here we go.
This looks like it could be.
Okay, found it, found it, found it.
I just went all the way around.
There we go.
Okay!
I'm scoping the future area.
I, uh, well, while you're doing that, I gotta pee.
Okay!
I'll be back.
Okay, doke.
What the heck is that?
What?
you minto i'm like minto where are you oh dear i just got
bit oh no there's still more antidote there's more antidote
where are you down it a little further ahead further ahead
okay let me let me find you but there's a giant rock that
looks so weird
giant rock yeah they pass through the the little door thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
Come look at this thing.
What is this?
What is that?
Has it got a face?
Or is it just me?
That's what I thought!
Yeah!
No!
Looks weird.
I thought it was like an enemy or something.
I was like, what is this thing?
Stonehenge, chat.
If it was Stonehenge, we wouldn't be getting up this close.
You'd be seeing it from about 5,000 miles away.
You better off just driving past it.
it in the car what is uh he's just what yeah what are you a
stonehenge hater no no i don't hate it but like you can't
you think it's overrated no you can't get that close to it
apart from like certain times like you go to the tour and
it's like you to be honest you get a better view from the
car just like driving past on the motorway yeah i thought
you could get right up on it i think You can sometimes.
Not always.
Hmm.
Yeah, this definitely has a face.
It does.
It looks like some kind of interpretive art or something.
It's like messing with my brain.
Yeah, that's a great question.
Huh.
Can we destroy it?
If we punch it?
We must be able to.
Punch it.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I'm going to push it to oblivion.
Oh, you might be right.
Maybe we have to get beers and push it.
Oh, you think so, actually.
Yeah, maybe because it's like it is moving because it's like
a different it's like a different kind of rock Yeah, I think
we need beers.
Okay.
All right.
Let's go get beers.
Okay It's unnatural.
Yeah
It's like a big swamp Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, I hear snakes Careful, we'll get to it when we get all
the way over here though forth with the beers and we'll run
out of energy yeah that's true i'm back are you guys at the
hello we're almost there
we found a big pushable rock that we're gonna need some
beers for it's creepy looking yeah it looks weird oh i
wonder what should we go do that right now first before we
drive no no it's kind of i think we should drive yeah okay
i'm ready to be unwinched you are you have been unwinched oh
i have been oh yeah oh okay i don't want to run you over
okay no it's okay i'm leading you i'm leading you this is i
put down a little log here to help you travel oh very the
van is not broken yet.
So that's a good sign.
good.
We can, we can wench this.
To victory.
We can.
We can wench this.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna have a beer so that I can try and push.
Oh, nope.
Never mind.
I can't get to the beers.
Okay.
Well, I'm gonna have a push anyway.
Push, push, push.
Yeah, I'm gonna also...
Oh!
It's working!
Go, go, go!
Oh, here, I'll help you.
It's working!
We're doing it!
Yeah!
It's actually working.
How is that possible?
Wanchit!
I think actually it's drivable now.
Yeah.
I think so.
Should I keep...
No shield, but...
Oh, yeah!
Oh, it's loose!
Yugi!
Yeah!
Let's try to...
Repair some stuff.
Yeah, we should fix before we keep going.
Like the door.
And the roof.
I'll get the wheels.
Hopefully we have enough scrap metal for all this.
I don't think we do.
Not for all of it.
Wait, there's some more though.
I saw some more.
Oh, nice.
there was more by where that snake was oh yeah okay let's
have a look by the mysterious rock yeah by the mystery rock
mystery rock i'll be careful wait if i die though john we
still have john we've been keeping oh my god watch out watch
out watch out i grabbed it i grabbed it nice Oh, he came
after behind you.
Hey, those burgers as well.
Anything else?
No, it looks good.
I don't know how you want to keep going from here, though.
Scared.
Yeah.
This ledge right here scares me just a little bit.
Me too.
It's up to you.
Yeah, do we want to put this plank over there?
Like, put the plank...
See what I mean?
Like, put the plank to a little mini bridge.
Let's see if that works.
If we put the planks, like a little mini bridge.
Oh, yeah, that's what...
Yeah, maybe.
Like that, but better executed.
Yeah, we have some...
There's some more that we can grab.
Oh, perfect.
Look at that.
I think that's the strat.
That's the way.
Maybe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There is the one that's up there.
Hold on, I'll go grab it.
Well, do you think it's easier just to go to the green part
over here and build a bridge this way?
Hmm.
Hum, hum, hum, hum, hum.
Hum, hum, hum, hum.
Here you go.
Here's another one.
Drive on the right here.
There's another plank.
Oh, thank you.
I thought yeet did that one.
Oh, there's one more over here.
I'm grabbing it.
I got it.
I'm yeeting it.
Yeet?
Yeet.
Oh.
perfect aim nice
that that looks beautiful very well constructed oh yeah um I
think maybe maybe it looks like three hairs sprouting out of
a head it does yeah we might want to repair the bathroom
soon having that exposed the elements is maybe a bit awkward
right is it really wait hold on let me check oh wow it's
open concept yeah open open plan thanks for closing the door
oh okay that was you in there okay wait wait let me let me
go around and get a view let me go around and get a view so
i'm just i'm gonna imagine i'm just like walking along i see
the camper van wow what a nice camper van man wow that's so
nice oh hello mint on the toilet i'm so sorry i shouldn't
have had those those street tacos oh no oh dear johnny
johnny johnny wait can i just jump in and join you in the
bathroom yeah i can oh you can you can hello that's lovely
so nice so do we just drive forward who is brave enough to
do it i can do it here i go yeah you could do it i believe
oh oh okay it works oh no hi hi hi hi hi yay oops uh run
over the snake um well where where do you now i just
realized we can go up here and go over the mysterious rock
we don't have to go over the mysterious rock to drive
through the mysterious rock oh yeah if you want to or we
could get some beers and try and do you want me to try and
see if it'll push just as a experiment yeah let's try it we
don't necessarily have to do it but i'm just intrigued to
see if the beers work i'm i'm intrigued too i'm curious wait
i'm bringing the whole pack i'm bringing the whole pack oh
thank you thank you thank you okay
whoa wait does move Yeah!
Wait, that's kind of crazy.
I wonder if we have to push it the opposite way because then
we would push it into like this little corner over here or
something so that we could drive through.
Perhaps.
Yeah.
I'm pushing.
What is that?
Oh wait, there's a second one!
Wait!
Wait, there's another one up here!
Oh!
What is this?
Oh, we might have to push that one down and like...
If we go up, I think we have to push it down.
But if we go through here, I think we only have to push this
one.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, so we're going to keep running down this way to see if
it's like the way forward.
Regardless, we'd have to push a rock.
Yes.
Whichever way we go.
Okay.
Another cube.
Oh, there's another plank challenge over here.
Oh!
jump queen jump queen jump queen wait where there's a jump
queen thing no no no no there's like a plank plank placing
challenge oh oh okay one of those things i'm releasing the
beers yeah beer grab one pull it away wait wait wait wait
wait let's get bees
I just want to push it this way.
Am I pushing it?
Well, I'm pushing.
Yeah!
Wait, it's moving!
Whoa!
Wait, this is not good.
Super, super strength.
Wait, it's now in the road.
We gotta push it to the side now.
Yeah, push it to the side.
Wait, I need another beer.
Hold my beer.
Okay, more beer.
More beer.
Where'd the beer go?
No, this might be enough space for it to go through.
You think so?
It might be.
Let me see.
Sorry, I already started driving up.
No, it's okay.
No, okay.
I mean, where do you find that beer?
Was there, like, a pack back here somewhere?
Yeah, I opened the pack, like...
Boy, where we first saw...
MCB.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, I see.
Oh, empty, empty beer, beer, beer.
Okay, here we go.
I didn't push it at all.
Is it trapped?
Like, something behind it, something?
Maybe.
Empty beer.
Beer.
Oh, I grabbed the beer.
Here, I'll throw the beer.
And I'll grab another beer.
Oh, wait.
Is it enough room?
It's enough room.
Yay!
Yippee!
Yeah!
Alright!
Celebratory beer!
Yeah!
Yeah, chugging, chugging, chug.
And litter.
Now on it fresher.
Alright, here we go.
On Earth Day!
Shh!
The Earth would be proud of us driving through here.
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't think it would be proud of us dropping all
those beer cans on the floor.
but sure yeah so so proud so thank you for the 50
memberships thank you thank you thank you thank you so much
happy earth day wow happy earth day hey there's there is
another jump challenge oh there is wait legit yeah i'm
trying to see what's at the top though where are you i'm in
the walls oh well i'm right behind the rv actually oh i see
oh i jumped over the rocks over here hi it's right here i
don't know how to get oh it's up here oh there's more scrap
wait there's actually a lot of stuff up here we can repair
behind the rv oh there's no hat though
I have no idea where are you oh up here oh I see okay yeah
wait a second can we cheese this
oh I like your thinking oh no oops I'm fine oh no oh no oh
no oh oh oh oh Oh, dear.
We shouldn't try.
It's only for scrap.
It's not worth it.
Wait, are you dead?
It wasn't worth it, guys.
It wasn't worth it.
You're laying so politely.
Wait, can you see me?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm so politely dead.
You're detached from your name tag.
Oh, no.
You're like 10 feet away from your name tag.
No, my name tag.
No, not your name tag.
What are the name tag enthusiasts going to do?
Oh, it's so sad.
Oh, no.
PB Chen Chibi.
How do I know who you are?
Will you revive me?
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Oh, and I should have asked you to make your case.
Yeah, I guess so.
Ugh, what's this?
It's mud.
Oh, no, it's fine.
No free revives.
This is the only.
Oh, this way.
Don't go to the mud, I think.
It might be dangerous.
I mean, mud.
I stepped in it.
It might be.
I think it was all right.
Never mind.
Eat it.
So we're not going to risk it.
It reminds me of one of those TV dinners that, like, had the
pudding in there.
Yeah, like the kids' cuisines.
Yeah.
If we do risk it, there's also an EpiPen.
I'm very lost.
How are you?
What do you mean?
Where are you?
I dropped down to the sound of my hammer.
Oh, I found the...
I found the...
I made it!
Yay!
You are the jump queen!
I did it.
Okay, now I gotta get back.
You are the jumping queen.
Um...
Oh, I'm not dead!
I'm not dead!
Hold me.
A turn.
Forever 19.
Yeah!
Okay.
Wait, where are you guys?
Oh, there's the van.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, I'm at the RV.
Scrap metal obtained.
Let's go.
Yeah, I repaired some.
So I hope you guys don't mind.
I think...
I think we have a bridge for the first one, at least.
Okay, I'll go forward now.
I believe.
Okay.
Wait, I'm actually stuck.
Oh, wait.
Am I parked?
Oh, there we go.
Do you see the...
Oh, wait.
Wait, not there.
Oh, sorry, I didn't see it.
Actually, it was there.
Is it bad?
Tell it to me straight, Doc.
Oh, there.
Let's go check out the situation.
Mmm.
Okay, go plan.
Go plan.
Push from there.
the front get a beer okay grab a beer grab a beer so right
oh i'm opening a six pack uh how do i do it okay okay
release the beer press release them release them all right i
got mine i think someone will need to be driving and in
reverse this my beer gone my beer there it is they're under
the table right i think we push the front of it Yeah, and
someone...
Did you say somebody has to be driving?
Yeah, I think someone should be in reverse.
Oh, okay, let me put this beard down.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, let me put it in reverse.
Oh, wait, my beard didn't last like two seconds.
Okay.
Oh, here we go.
Let me go.
Push it!
Wait, I think it's working!
uh yeah yeah i'm going in i'm going in okay no more push i'm
scared i'm scared i'm scared i'm scared uh i'm stuck nah i'm
stuck hmm oh did this do anything well it uh yeah yeah you
moved i i've got to go forward probably i think we need more
bears Wait, if you go forward, you're going to be stuck in
the hole.
All wheel drive, baby.
All wheel drive.
Wait, maybe if I could put the plank down for you.
Girl, girl, girl, girl.
I was on that plank.
Can you give me some warning?
I'm dead.
Oh.
No, you're not.
I'm dead.
Oh, yeah, let's just grab this plank while Vicky is
standing.
You fell!
You fell 20 centimeters!
Don't even...
Bruh.
I can't believe this.
Admittedly, I was nearly dead when it happened, but still.
You have, like, bones of glass.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, Phoebe, you're doing it.
Yes, Phoebe, yes.
I'm not doing anything.
No, it's definitely- it looks like the snake.
It looks like the snake.
So I'm just gyrating in place.
Oh, disgusting.
Don't look at me.
I'm embarrassed.
Look, don't look.
Oh, she's such a freak, you guys.
Wow.
I think she likes it.
Everybody watching.
Freaky.
Oh, my goodness.
Wow.
Oh, damn.
That's not a Mika, what's not another RV?
A park, a park, a park, a park, a park, a park, a park.
Okay, can I get out?
Can I get out of here?
I am out of here.
It's a little bit of a tough zone.
Sorry, I missed this up.
I had no idea.
We can't winch it, huh?
Um, wait, let's see if they provide any poles in the future.
Yeah, I'm looking for poles.
I'm on a pole journey.
I'm coming with you.
All right.
It's got to be something.
The annoying thing is all of this bit looks quite far.
It looks absolutely fine.
So annoying.
Why did they do this?
They gave us such a tough little area.
Wait, I see a repair station down here.
They might have...
Oh, we're so close to the repair.
We are.
We're so close to the garage.
I know.
um maybe we can make it through maybe we're so close we can
make it there is doesn't seem to wait uh doesn't seem to be
any darn lots of scrap metal though yeah well we're getting
to the water is this going to be Oregon Trail for real?
Dissentary.
I'm gonna play Oregon Trail for the first time at some
point.
You are!
Yeah!
I want to.
Baby's first Oregon Trail.
Yeah!
Wait, how do we get here?
Oh, over here.
Water!
I know, I think we have to...
What is it called when you have...
in the Oregon Trail when you have to float the river?
Is that what it was called?
Float the river?
I can't remember.
Maybe?
I think so.
Does anyone remember?
The water looks so nice and clear.
Makes you want to go for a swim.
Ford the river.
Wait, you really can just walk on the mud?
That's crazy.
There's a zombie game based on Oregon Trail.
Yeah.
There it is.
Apparently.
Yeah.
huh there's some nuggets i don't eat those winch it to the
nuggets yeah true true wait why couldn't they give us one
single pole just one yeah we're so close to this to the
service area thing yeah so annoying um is there anything
wait there is a tree oh there is a single tree oh it might
be too far but i'm gonna try we believe we believe i don't
know if i can reach up there
oh i got it yeah i got it i got it oh my gosh mint phantom
genius okay you the controller oh my gosh throw it to me oh
okay thank you i'll throw it to you you got it and then oh
you could do it too i i'm scared okay okay what how do i do
it okay i'm just gonna i'm gonna watch and learn all right
here we go okay here we go oof do i need to push oof do i
need to push Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
It worked!
Oh, we might want to park it.
Oh, our cars.
Yeah, we might want to repair.
We got four scrap, baby.
Ouch.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Who did I pick up?
I'm so sorry.
I do not want you to die from getting bonked.
I like how we're still in reverse.
Beep.
Ouch.
Okay.
It's a little bit repaired.
I think it's enough to get us through.
And then we can go repair the rest.
Yeah!
Oh, wait.
I'm stuck again.
Yeah.
Uh, maybe we should push you.
Wait, hold on.
I got it.
I just...
Wait, maybe I have...
I got it.
I'm going to get it for a second.
I'm going to get the beers ready.
We're good.
I'm going to release a beer.
Nice.
Everything's fine, everybody.
No problemo at all.
There's never been a problem.
Yippee!
Never ever.
Okay, I just got to not go into the water, too.
Wouldn't that be, like, so crazy?
I've got a beer ready to go in case I need to push.
Oh, my gosh, but we're there.
We're there.
We made it.
Wow!
Yeah!
Checkpoint five.
I know.
Out of how many.
Whoa.
That was incredible, guys.
Yovi, can you go forward a tiny bit?
Oh, yeah.
Hoi.
Yay, thank you.
Very nice.
I wish we had some more scrap, though.
Some beers to celebrate, everybody.
Campo!
Cheers!
How many is that now, Vicky?
How many is that now?
You don't want to know.
I'm sure it's fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Totally not.
I'm sure it's fine.
Mm-hmm.
Ten.
Yeah.
Look how beautiful the water is.
Wow, it's so nice.
It's beautiful.
Doesn't it remind you?
We have a nice cold beer.
Actually, I think it does.
Yeah, me too.
I'll have another one.
To be fair, we do have loads.
We have like, oh no, now we do, oh my gosh, how many do I
have?
We've already got one pack left.
Or rather, you had a lot.
Oh no, you had loads.
Yeah, we had loads.
Uh-oh.
Oh, okay, I'm fine.
Never mind.
I'm looking for more scrap, but I'm not seeing anything.
I can't believe we made it.
Oh, so nice.
We did it.
We did it!
Yummy!
Hey, where are you guys?
I want to jump in celebration, but I can't see you.
Oh, there you are.
I'm going to skinny dip in the water.
Yep.
Can we remove our clothes in this game?
I have a mod that lets me.
Okay.
Come on.
Oh, wow.
Here I go.
Woo!
Yeah!
Oh, it's so nice.
Oh, the water's fine.
I can see you guys.
Oh, my gosh.
I can see you just, like, walking in the water.
It's so cute.
I wonder, there might be scrap over here, actually.
Maybe.
Actually, there is none.
I think it's a whole load of nothing.
Yeah, it's actually a whole load.
out of nothing over here.
Mother nature is not nothing.
No, that's true.
Mother nature is beautiful.
Happy Earth Day, everybody.
Happy Earth Day.
This beautiful beautiful lake in the middle of a mountain.
So nice.
Yeah.
This is where the Loch Ness Monster lives.
I wonder what kind of creatures are in here because it's so
isolated.
Yeah, we haven't seen any living things except for Johnny
and a bunch of bears.
Or one bear that keeps terrorizing us?
I don't know.
Yeah, it's either one bear.
Imagine it's just one bear with a vendetta.
I hate these damn campers.
He hates us.
Oh, the snakes.
I think, well, the snakes.
That's right.
Ooh, we're going into a cave, you guys.
This is exciting.
Whoa, that is exciting for next time.
Oh, my gosh.
That is exciting.
Yeah.
Oh, it's beautiful.
Maybe we'll see more creatures in there.
Maybe bats?
Hmm.
Crabs.
Ooh, bats.
Exciting.
A serial killer?
Um...
I hope not.
That, too, is wild.
I hope not with a bear, and we kept seeing a bear.
I like the bear.
To be fair, you did try to blow up the bear.
That's because he was coming out.
after us.
She was.
And guys, can we just say, you know, we have Johnny still
with us.
We didn't make Johnny into actually, where is Johnny?
Wait, where is Johnny?
He's up there.
No, he's up there.
Okay, okay.
It's all good.
Johnny is still with us.
We didn't make him into burgers.
I'm proud of us.
Nope.
Yeah.
This is the best run.
It is.
So, uh, see you guys in another six months for the rest of
this game.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna die, hopefully.
In six months.
It was so much fun.
I love, I love Avi Day with you guys.
I really, really like this with you guys, too.
It's so fun.
So fun.
We should play more friend slop, though.
Oh, I agree, I agree.
I really like friend slop.
Like, I liked content warning a lot.
Content warning.
That was fun.
Which one was that one?
It's the one where you have to find spooky things, but then
you have to film it for TikTok.
Oh, I haven't played that one.
Oh, it's kind of fun.
Is it?
I want to do Elden Ring Night Rain with you guys.
It's three people, and I think it'll be fun.
I've been wanting to find people to play with.
Let's do it.
Oh, we do it?
We could do it.
Yeah.
We could.
any Elden Souls rings ever.
Don't worry.
I've played Elden Ring and I'm just finishing off Dark Souls
right now so I can I can try and carry but then I'll still
probably be really bad but I'll do my best.
It'll be fun.
Okay.
I believe.
Any announcements from you guys?
Any cool streams you got coming up or whatever before we
head off?
Let's start with Minto from left.
Yes, Minto.
Yes.
Have a
good...
Yeah, okay, Phoebe.
Thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you.
That's very sweet.
An earlier K-Barn for the Supa as well.
well thank you uh keyboard says most burgers are pretty
tasty though i've not tried i've tried a bison burger and
that stuff is so tasty it is it's so delicious it's my die
osusume there's a place that i've seen that serves a some
from your osusume maybe i will try yeah oh someone said next
weekend is Oshi Uplink and we will all be there we have a
meet and greet and also a little mini concert roulette duet
roulette thing that's going on so if you are in Canada
Toronto we hope to see you there yeah please please come by
say hello yeah please please yuppie yuppie next weekend is
also or Friday at least, Itu Demo Touch will be releasing on
Bandcamp and also all streaming platforms.
So, stream Itu Demo Touch.
Stream Itu Demo Touch.
Yay, yay, yay, yay, yay, yay, yay.
Wait, you can nod like that.
Oh my gosh, that's so cool,
I'm going to get him.
...he deserves to be in this...
Oh, wait, I can't get him.
We have no...
We have no ladder.
Maybe I can still grab him.
I got him.
Yes, Johnny!
ETH ETH ETH ETH ETH ETH ETH ETH DORGO says, Thanks for the
stream.
It's super fun watching you all play this together.
Great teamwork pulling through.
And glad that Johnny's still with us.
Yes, lots of luck.
Look at him.
Look at him!
Johnny!
go go go go go go go go go go
what kind of get done get go
that looks that looks amazing oh my god vicky do you have
any announcements oh no particularly just uh got some some
streams at the weekend sonic and some singing and stuff but
main thing yeah main thing is next weekend oh she uplink
meet and greet in concert we will see you there yes very
exciting until next time you'll have a very we'll have
another collab next month watch this space about what that
will be but yes thank you very much everybody do we have
Otsukare sama densetsu version we keep forgetting it we keep
forgetting and coming up with something new every time Otsu
yeah Otsu go vote for Kogimune in the Sanrio character
rankings is that why I changed to the hoodie every day Otsu
dance Otsu dance Otsu dance!
Otsu dance, guys!
Otsu dance!
Bye bye!